hi welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google Cloud we are hosting
webinars every Tuesday my name is
Karthik and today I'll be talking about
building modern apps using an API for
strategy you can ask questions anytime
on the platform and we have Googlers on
standby to answer them with that let's
get started here's a quick look at the
agenda we are going to spend a few
minutes understanding a problem how
average you can help you solve those
problems some of the high-level
architectures which are needed to solve
the problem we are going to see a quick
demo and then we should have a few
minutes for Q&A at the end the first
obvious question is why should we even
care about this topic why do you need to
build modern applications using an API
for strategy and the simple answer is
the whole aspect of modernization is
such a huge driver we have to modernize
every aspect of our life right we are
modernizing our phones every year we are
modernizing our smart homes and all
aspects of a life and this modernization
also obviously trickles down into every
aspect of of an enterprise or a start of
whoever you might be if you look at the
IT landscape the software landscape that
is changing a lot normally over the last
you know 10 15 20 years we would talk
about our legacy architectures our
websites mobile apps partners even
mobile is pretty new right mobile is
maybe even the last 5-10 years when it
became mainstream but that itself is
changing drastically if you look at
where the world is going towards we are
talking about IOT x' and connected
platforms like connected cars
omni-channel strategies the backend
systems are moving more and more towards
micro services we are talking about
chatbots and AI based BOTS machine
learning we are talking about various
kind of cloud integrations on how to
integrate across multiple clouds and SAS
applications how to migrate your
existing applications from your on-prem
datacenters to flower
how to build hybrid architectures so
these are drastically different
landscape than what you have today a lot
of this also is delivered through api's
keep in mind when you want to expose
your data to the connected car sort your
eye or tees or to your chat BOTS there
is an API behind all of that the EPA's
themselves are changing as well right
the designs of the APS are changing when
we first started seriously thinking
about API is first there was RPC style
API is way back in early 90s so became
really popular in May 2000 and all and
then now the world has more or less move
towards rest but there are other formats
of API is like Oh data or graph QL or
WebSockets or g RPC and there are so
many different just design patterns of
api's which are existent and that's a
constantly evolving landscape the
security of those API is also changes
right so we used to have sam'l or TLS
based or IP based whitelisting or things
like ntlm kerberos in the past which is
mostly given its way to things like Auto
Panetta connect or GWT or even basic
auth so what happens is as new and newer
technologies comes up some part of your
stack adopts let's say some part will
adopt JWT or affinity connect but you
will have some other stack which is
still running on sam'l or running on
mutual TLS there's even a brand new
proposal for a security standard called
buffet which came out last year is an
open source standard from Google for
managing service to service
communications in a micro services world
so this is a constantly evolving
landscape in terms of API security the
other thing which changes are the
consumers previously all the API switch
used to have that used to go and either
serve internal applications or maybe a
website or maybe one web optimized
mobile app but now you are building
native applications in Android you are
building you know various kinds of
connected experiences you are building
iOS apps
IOT apps smart home
all sorts of different consumers you are
you are creating this API serving up to
so all this change inevitably results in
where you have to have an IT
infrastructure where you have to manage
a number of different versions of your
API so you might have some soap some
rest you have few different versions of
rest you might have some some graph QL
api's and whatnot you have a different
types of security protocols you might
have different API standards which
internally leads to inefficient
developer on boardings right because you
need to onboard more and more developers
for from internal different different
parts of the organization's or from your
partners or the long tail of developers
because you need different developers
with different key skill sets right as
we are going to more and more different
discrete backends different styles of
api's how do you onboard these different
developers how do you onboard the
different apps onto your platform and
how do you release faster and better the
new versions of those apps how do you
manage the lifecycle of the keys because
as you have different consumers you need
to you need to have a much better
control on when a certain key can be
invalidated or when someone is not
following your TNC you can you can mark
that as a red flag and all of these
challenges also results in a massive
challenge with the overall analytics how
do you measure all the usage errors
latency adoption because you need to
measure things from your operational
standpoint right how do you like across
all the different API is how is your
average error rate or what's the average
latency but you also need to understand
it from the business standpoint how's
your adoption of the brand-new API which
you just published or the brand new
version of the API and you need to
understand all the usage and adoption
how is a specific type of API getting
more use in a mobile app context than
something else which might be more
popular with with IOT devices now now we
have looked at some of the problems
right that because of this
changing landscape which your back-end
is changing and your API is are changing
and your consumers are changing now
comes the obvious question as part of as
part of this changing landscape
how can a PG play a role and how can a
PG help you evolve faster so a PD helps
at a very nutshell a PG health by
creating a platform so if you look at if
you look at the bottom half that's where
you have your Google cloud platform you
have your maybe some other clothes maybe
some on-premise maybe some on providers
based system and these are all have
running a bunch of systems which are
exposing data which needs to go up to
different web and Android and iOS and
different set of consumers essentially
right so what's the platform a platform
is a place where you can bring these
different technologies and the human
aspects of the technologies like the
developers who are building those
back-end systems and developers are
consuming those back-end systems the
developers were then building the apps
and then the end users of the apps you
can break all of them together so after
she can help you in your journey of
modernization by bringing all these
different entities together so in the
apogee platform which sits as a facade
or a proxy on top of your back-end
systems Apogee will take care of things
like providing you all the right
analytics from operations to from
operational analytics to you know
infrastructure analytics to business
analytics it will help you manage all
the developers a lifecycle of the
developers from the developers are
producing the API is to the developers
who are consuming those as well as all
aspects of security translation and
debugging and a whole bunch of things
and we'll see that a little later right
but the key aspect is a pitch is a
platform helps you tie back together all
the technologies both of the produced
production side as well as a consumption
side as well as all the different human
elements in this platform helps you tie
it all back together
now oftentimes where we are talking
about this we get asked questions that
hey I I would like to go there right
where we create this platform but
over the years I mainly have built
monoliths or that's what we are left
with right so in that in a more alert
world you would typically have all this
different all these different
capabilities like authentication
authorization business rules etc all can
find in the boundaries of the same
application which are then consumed by
different users that's a very very
traditional landscape in an IT world now
people inherently understand the problem
with with a with the model is like that
so early two-thousands the world of so a
service-oriented architecture that
gradually became popular and became
mainstream and that's when people
started to break those individual
components and individual services these
are we are still talking about you know
primarily soap with maybe some
saml-based security or certificate based
security but this is how fun for many of
us that's how the architecture looks
like and not really a very traditional
monolith now as the world evolved right
like we're it's 2018 for everyone we are
no longer investing new into solar
services or or sam'l or soap or things
like that rather the new keyword that
you buzz what is micro services how can
you build things which are even smaller
and are easier to manage and we can
leverage things like containers and
kubernetes and stuff like that to to
grow them to scale them in a hybrid
environment or the bigger cloud eran
primeur multi cloud or what not so now
we have a lot of micro services as part
of everyday stacks if you look at how
enterprises typically look today you
will probably see a combination of a
whole bunch of different things so let's
start with the most obvious on the
right-hand side where you can see cloud
foundries and Dockers and bale metals
and VMs that's your traditional
on-premise environment right when you
have a data center or a Colo facility
where you are either running bare metals
or VMs or running you know containers
like docker or doing other kind of
on-prem softwares
from there some enterprises have evolved
to run private cloud where you are doing
not only lay Dockers where you are
actually try to run cloud foundries and
kubernetes on-prem and trying to create
a private cloud in your data center or
in your Cola facilities now the next
thing is a public cloud so you will
probably be using a whole lot of GCP
maybe some other private cloud other
public clouds in a hybrid environment
and then you have the SAS where you
might be using things like G suite and
using the api's so the key takeaway is
this is a reality for every enterprise
whether you are a fortune 2,000
organization who has been in business
for a hundred years or whether you are a
startup who just started out of the
Silicon Valley over the last few years
your back-end that the systems from
where you're consuming data and the
systems to where you are exposing those
data that is becoming more and more
diverse right so let's move on to now
often I say we talk about this we get
the feedback that hey this is not what
our back it really looks like right this
is probably where we would want to go
but this is not where it looks like
right so and that's the question which
we get often times that my architecture
does not look like that today it might
be true for some parts of your business
maybe for some applications that may not
be others but that's totally fine right
if your architecture does not look like
that and that's totally fine because
most likely your architecture looks like
this so we talked about the small elite
and how that's how monolith has been a
mainstay in in enterprises for many many
many years so this was probably how your
application looks like you have a
monolith in this case we are talking
about let's say a retail experience
where you have a monolith application
which has search shopping-cart
type-ahead recommendations CMS and all
these capabilities running inside a
datacenter
these are exposing all these
capabilities which are then consumed by
different
web applications or Android or iOS
applications so monolith exposing some
API is which are then consumed by those
web Android iOS oftentimes you will see
you probably don't even know the
existence of the API is because of two
reasons either either the monolith down
below exposes us decays and the SDK in
turn hides those api's or maybe the
monolith itself provides you direct into
into the web Android iOS is the same
team who builds those and there is a
very deep integration between those
consumer facing applications and that
back-end right but the challenge is that
now the front end and the back end those
are now the front and the back end those
are very tightly integrated so what we
need to do is we need to create a proxy
or a facade we need to we need to
separate those two things out and that's
why Apogee fits in a PGX or a proxy or a
facade with sits in between that
back-end layer where you have the
monolith and you have the front-end
layer so first and foremost this gives
you a tremendous flexibility on the
front-end team to do things differently
at a different pace then what would
happen in the backend now let us look
into how will that happen in real life
so let's say you have this monolith and
now the back-end team decided that we
need to break it down this monolith we
want to create a few micro services
let's say we want to break down the
search and the type ahead and write some
new services maybe a property lookup and
what not which is not available today as
part of the monolith back-end and now
they are writing this thing in in micro
services in Chi ke running on Google
cloud platform now because Apogee is
sitting in front of as an abstraction
layer in front of this back-end
while the back-end teams are making
those changes
they are moving those services to Google
cloud platform which which takes a long
time right which takes maybe six months
here are two years the front-end teams
they are not impacted because they are
getting still those same API sand Apogee
is taking care of
of translating they're meditating them
right like so when when the Google cloud
platform based there's the micro
services are built there so the API is
might be exposed as JSON over rest
whereas the monolith might expose soap
Appaji will make sure that what the
Android and the web and iOS team see
that's single uniform api is
irrespective of what the backend is it
is the same security it has the same
versioning structure it has the same
let's say the layer of caching and
everything else like the backend whether
it is in a monolith or whether it is in
GCP so what it leads to is a front-end
team now gets isolated as you can see we
can now create one nice box around those
different front-end different front-end
teams because you might have a different
team for web a different team for
Android different team from iOS and now
there is an ice box where they can work
themselves having at an arm's length
from the back-end team so we are now
trying to break away from the paradigm
that the backend and the front-end teams
are very closely knit together but every
feature on the front end result said in
deep code change at the backend right
like where we have seen things like if
you want to build a new feature in your
Android app it might result in having a
stored procedure change at your database
level right that's obviously not ideal
and it slows down the whole whole
process so now what you can see is maybe
as part of this Realty texture what the
retail customer wants to do is they want
to move everything on to GCP as
different services and and they want to
keep in their private cloud or in the
data center they want to keep the
shopping cart application because it
doesn't make sense to rewrite that as a
micro service or what not while they're
doing that as you can imagine this is a
there's a massive change they are doing
massive reworking and it and it is
happening over here's maybe ensure the
front-end timing slowing down well they
have been asked that hey we are making
those massive changes at the backend
please make your changes slower instead
of that they actually added brand-new
brand-new capabilities like they might
have added a new Google home integration
or they might have added some other
native mobile apps or some new web apps
so the beauty with Apogee is you can
create this you can create this facade
or a proxy layer where you can where you
can have the front-end teams building
new new apps faster going through faster
release cycles of the apps while your
back-end going goes through this this
tremendous transformative changes where
you are shifting or back-end either from
monoliths and taking it to a lift and
shift of cloud or building or the hybrid
cloud or building out micro services
breaking out here more or less into
micro services whatever shape or form
those changes might be it will help you
isolate those changes at the backend and
your front-end teams will still be able
to innovate at a lot faster pace than
probably where where they were before
now how Apogee does that this this
diagram talks about something which is
which is more commonly known as to speed
IT or a multimodal IT these are the
words which have been thrown around in
the IT world in the last few years so
what does that mean is down below where
you see the CRM and the financials HR
supply chain and all of that there's a
system of Records that's the layer which
you hardly ever want to touch right you
don't want to go and change your users
database schema every every few days or
every few even every few months maybe
that changes once every couple of years
so you want to the pace of change over
there is very very slow in matter of
years but at the top you have your
systems of engagement so this is where
you have your you know the web apps and
mobile apps either employees apps or
consumer facing apps or partner apps and
whatnot now at that layer you need to
move a lot faster you need to move in
matter
of matter of days if you have an app out
in Google Play and you get a feedback
that something is not right you cannot
wait for 18 months to fix it you cannot
even wait for maybe 18 days to fix it so
that's what Apogee comes in with his
ability to manage the security the
scalability the analytics manage all the
developers Apogee helps as the next of
the cushion where it takes those system
of Records as the slow-moving layer and
makes the radar system of engagement
where you can move a lot faster so this
is an example of how Apogee fits in in a
Google cloud platform context so let's
say you are writing your back-end you
have the system of records down below
which are untouched like your CRM s and
financials and inventory and HR and
whatnot then you are using Google cloud
platform on top of that to do a whole
bunch of things you might be running
Google cloud pub/sub logging data flow
big tables computes and things like that
the cloud pub/sub or the login or the
business logic which is running an app
engine those are then all exposed out to
your clients which are maybe IOT s or
mobile apps or web apps or partners or
whatnot
Apogee sits as a facade in between these
two and make sure all the data which is
exposed from Google cloud platform both
strategy and average it takes care of
managing all the API is a security the
operational aspect the analytics creates
a developer portal through which all the
developers on a client-side they can
they can get access to those API is
easily do the bot protections if you get
attacked by spams after the built in
bought detection built built in if you
aren't even monetize some of those API
is that capability also is built in as
part of that platform now these are the
abilities wise right what you are
looking at from an RPG so if you if you
look at RPG the two key the two key
trends on both sides are the machine
learning and the NIE which we use at
many parts of the platform down below is
a runtime where you have the enterprise
gateway and sto then you have a
mediation engine which takes care of
security your transformation from exo
restore XML to JSON you have connectors
to which you can write a node or Python
or things like that you can build
orchestrations that one call comes in
just let it out and a few different
calls go to the south part then there is
all sorts of analytics from business
analytics to operations analytics and
then you have the whole developer
ecosystem where you have the API
catalogs you have client SDKs you are
taking your API is and creating products
so Appaji kind of makes you think your
API is as individual products just like
you will treat your every other go to
market product and then you can create
an API marketplace or you can create or
you can actually sell those API is using
the monetization capabilities so this is
how the API platform looks like
capabilities why is at a very high level
we are going to now jump into a quick
demo of everything we talked about I
have a very simple setup the demo setup
says I have two different applications
which is serving some hotels data we got
some hotels data all loaded up into into
GCP and then I have a node.js app which
is running in Google compute engine in
regular VMs and then I have a spring
boot app which is running in gke the
google kubernetes engine and both of
these apps are exposing api's which are
their proxies through Appaji and goes
through different consumers in the
apogee world the different consumers are
are represented by apps so I have two
different apps which are consuming those
those api's one interesting thing is so
we are using the VM compute engine that
is kind of reminiscent to a legacy
application right how you run your
traditional VM based apps and the
springboard app which is running in gke
is like your modern is your modern
application we also have an API
developer portal this is where we expose
all the details of those api's which can
then be subscribed to and then consumed
by the developers who wants to build the
different different apps
with that let me switch screen and jump
into into the demo alright so what you
see is is a picture of a nice hotel
so this is our fictitious hotel and this
is where the hotel's developer portal is
if you are not familiar with what a
developer portal is a great example for
you to take a look at is go to
developers.google.com right so this is
one single page through which Google
interacts with all these developers and
please keep in mind this is not only for
for public use cases or for longtail of
developers cases if your large
enterprise if you are building api's
internally and if you have hundreds of
developers are equal very similar to
this like a def portal is extremely easy
to build this platform to build this
ecosystem inside our enterprise as well
right so please keep it please take a
look at this developers.google.com this
developer portal and what Apogee helps
you to do is build a developer portal
just like that for your enterprise
either a private developer portal or a
semi-private means it can be invitation
only to your partners or you can have it
a true public developer portal so this
is one such developer portal which you
built for a demo we call it hotels R Us
and as part of this def portal we have
some API so we have some pretty simple
looking pages but let's say I have this
API called C map demo synapse hotels and
there are a bunch of hotels api's here I
can see an API for get all hotels or get
a hotel using a particular hotel name or
reviews or inventory or whatnot now what
I can do is I can simply go here and I
can try out this API and I can execute
it and I can see the request on a
response now this is based on open API
which was previously known as swagger
so when you import a swagger definition
or the open API definition into a PG a
PG can automatically create this
create this dynamic page for you
the beauty of this is without without
something like this previously you would
have to you know probably ask request
access for an API I have to wait for a
few days if not a few months someone
have to give you access documentation so
maybe a PDF and then you take those and
you know then write some client code and
then only you can have your API is make
the first call to your API right this is
a process which takes which would have
taken a long time a lot of trial and
errors not easy to get support and
things like that so now with a developer
portal anyone can come and can learn
about the API at this stage you are
accessing a sandbox environment you are
not have access to the production when
you want to get access to the production
then the developer have to go in and log
in right over there
and he can ask for support for various
things they can log in they can get keys
they can you can then approve those keys
for getting used in production and only
when you are certain about what kind of
app the developer is building and things
like that you can have him who's your
production API so an app is you takes
care of creating the segregation between
sandbox and the production and how do
you do app promotion how do you certify
your developer and all that kind of
stuff all right
now let's see an aperture screen so this
is what we call the management Hawaii so
when you log into Apogee at just a
pitch-dark on slash edge with your in
your SAS environment this is what you
are going to see one of the first things
most likely you are going to do is
create an API proxy right so the proxy
is really the facade which is which is
separating out your back-end from the
front ends so over here I have a whole
bunch of I have a whole bunch of facade
a whole bunch of proxies but I'm going
to open up this particular proxy which
if you can see it is it has two
different backends which he talks to so
one is that legacy back-end which I
talked about which is the legacy
and the other is the more modern
application and both of these are
exposed as one single application so the
immediate beauty is that when a consumer
is trying to call they are going to just
call this endpoint cause /v 1 slash
hotels they don't know whether
downstream it is going to the legacy
application or to the modern gke based
application that is something which
Apogee can take care of dynamically and
can route it to different backends so
when you move on to the when you move on
to this particular screen call develop
this is where it becomes a lot more
interesting and you can actually see all
the different get all hotels get all
hotel details and all that kind of stuff
so these are the different API calls
which averages configure to process
right now and I'll not spend a lot of
time on this but this is what we call a
proxy editor or policy editor we are
using different kinds of policies you
can configure all sorts of things from
put right amount of quota or spike
erased or caching or security and and do
orchestrations and version management
and things like that
let me quickly jump on to this screen
called the trace so trace is a life to
bugger if you have ever written a code
you have most likely used a debugger in
in your IDE so trace is such a debugger
right so this is where I have I have a
script running which is sending some API
calls and I can see those API calls
actually coming in and I can actually
click on a particular call and I can see
how the call came in the different
policies which it is invoking like there
is invoking a policy to verify API key a
policy to remove the quota policy there
are some conditions and finally the call
goes to the backend I can actually then
go down and see all the different
parameters with that particular policy
affected so this is an awesome way for
you to debug things in in real life and
you can export this session and can do
an offline tracing at a later on now let
me move on to a little bit different
screen so we created this UI a very
simple hotels app
if I click down below you will actually
see it has been configured to use that
v1 slash hotels and I am passing an API
key so as part of the demo setup I
created two apps right think of one is a
legacy app and one is a modern earth
both of these apps cause the same API v1
slash hotels now based on the API key
with which the call with which the app
is configured the call will go to a
different backends so Apogee is checking
at that API key and is and is discerning
which one of the backends this
particular app is configured to so if I
actually go ahead and place a search for
Seattle and I will get all the details
from the backend application right so
this is a very very simple demo but but
what I what we are hoping the key
takeaways you can see the simplicity
that you are exposing one single
interface to all sorts of applications
whether your legacy applications which
you are scared to touch right because
the original developer is no longer with
a company for many many years or to the
modern Android apps all of them get the
same interface and then Apogee can
dynamically redirect them to different
different backends and you can do so
many other things like you know manage
different versions manage different
styles of API different security
capabilities of the api's and whatnot
one of the things which I wanted to show
you guys today is the analytics
capability because as you have mode as
you have more and more different styles
of API higher usage of this API is
larger number of developers using those
API is the analytics becomes very
critical because you need to understand
very precisely how each developer or how
each app is using those API is at what
error rate what latency were throughput
what is the business justification for
an API and things like that so I have
one analytics which is open which over
the last one day is showing me worse my
overall total traffic my success versus
error rate my average response times my
traffic by different proxy so it might
be a user's API
and I have a catalogue API how do I know
which API is getting used more often and
at what error rate and what throughput
and whatnot I can look into things like
API monitoring which actually helps me
see what are the you know what are the
last five hours of of my latency or the
error rate and what is the total traffic
for individual api's I can actually go
in and can drill down and see okay I can
configure thresholds that hey I want to
get alerted every time the throughput
goes or let's say the error rate goes
beyond 0.1% and things like that looks
like I have a little less data than what
I anticipated so we'll move on to some
of the other analytics things like
deficit for engagement which is really
popular with product managers here you
can see I can look at all the different
developers the the details like proxy
name and things like that then what apps
you are using and I can then I can then
drill down and analyze individual
individual applications so I can say hey
this developer is making a lot of calls
from their Android app and I want to see
how is their pattern different from you
know last seven days versus this seven
days and things like that there are a
whole bunch of other analytics like
error code analytics or geo map which
helps you to get an awesome overview of
analytics data or the traffic coming
from all around the world and you can
see that immediately calls coming from
Virginia and I can drill down and see
where in Virginia the calls coming in
from you can see your traffic error rate
you know average response times and all
those things and how are they
distributed over the over the world so
I'm going to pause there this is just
please keep in mind this is just a very
high-level overview of appaji and we
have not even touched probably 10% of
the of the overall platform capabilities
there's a lot more feel free to try out
the platform at Apogee comm just go and
sign up and you should be able to get
the same interface as you are saying now
and I'm going to pause there please
stay tuned for Q&A we have a few
questions coming in during the whole
during a whole session we'll be back in
just less than a less than a minute
you
alright looks like we got a few
questions during the during the session
let me try to address them as best as I
can
the first question is can I use Apogee
even if we are not using kubernetes ogk
the answer is yes
so Apogee is a very much back-end or
platform agnostic Apogee only cares
about HTTP or HTTPS so it doesn't matter
whether you are running gke or or even
you whether running in GCP and while
we're running your private cloud your
on-prem data centers might be Cloud
Foundry or whatever it might be as long
as that application talks HTTP or HTTPS
you can use Apogee on top of that and
you can also use other protocols using
custom connectors using things like you
can talk to you know TCP based protocols
and things like that so the answer is
absolutely yes
primarily HTTP and HTTPS and other
protocols using custom characters the
second question is I don't have mobile
apps is Appaji still relevant
absolutely interestingly you will
actually see traditionally if you look
at how enterprise the view strategy one
of the one of the starting points in
many cases is they use Apogee two to
streamline their API so internally
irrespective of where the mobile apps
are whether you have mobile apps or web
apps or IO DS or whatnot
because a challenge which typically
happens in almost every enterprise of
every size that over the years people
write different kinds of API different
styles different versions you know and
how do you even get a how do you even
get a good control on this API is like
who are using those api's where's the
usage pattern but you know all that kind
of stuff so yes we have a lot of
customers who use Apogee with mobile
apps but using but the weather who the
consumer is that's kind of not so much
critical as long as a consumer talks API
is for the consumer talks on HTTP and
HTTPS based protocol right so just to
reiterate the answer is absolutely yes
for the second one
third question can I have different
security protocols for my different
api's this is actually becoming more and
more relevant and more and more common
because as we see enterprises who have
started modernizing even companies you
know who are pretty new who started
there who have been in existence event
for like five years they may have
started with something like auth and
bearer tokens and now you might have
evolved into JW T's or open and connect
and and other protocols or maybe spiffy
which I mentioned earlier obviously
other enterprises who have been there
much longer they might have a lot of
other older protocols like Kerberos or
or sam'l and whatnot what you can do
with Apogee is you can do something
Elektra initial mediation what it means
is on a southbound that is a PG to the
backend you will have this individual
different protocols and there are
northbound side which is the client to a
Fiji
you can have you can have one standard
protocol maybe you want to standardize
an auth maybe couple of different flows
of auth and you can have the client of
true RPG using just those two authority'
calls and then Apogee on a southbound
will translate that to sam'l or JWT or
affinity connect or or TLS or whatever
might be applicable great question the
next one can Apogee analytics data be
exported yes there are a few different
options so all the analytics data which
you saw and a lot of others we showed it
not you can export there 20 pi you can
do pretty much a raw export or there is
a pretty powerful query syntax through
which you can export just just parts of
the analytics data and you can also
there is also a native integrations with
things like bigquery where you can
directly export all the data to bigquery
so that you can do further analysis in
GCP next question how can a Pidgey
manage different versions of my api
again great question so there are two
aspects to doctor to that question right
one is how the platform can do and one
is what are the best practices of
version
so let me address the first question
first so you can manage follow for
Apogee different versions of API are
just different API right whether you
represent those versions as query
parameters or two header sorts of
foreign parameters those are just
different endpoints and a virtual manage
just added will manage two different API
is happy will also provide you analytics
out-of-the-box through which you can see
how different how the adoption of
different versions are and you know you
can take business decisions when to run
us when to cut off a specific version or
when can you or which version is getting
adoption and how can a fine tune and
adjust those now in terms of best
practices we have you know we have we
have seen a lot of versioning over the
years and we have certain best practices
on whether you should do versioning
through URLs or through foreign patterns
or through headers
how it should vary based on the style of
api's and things like that you can go
over to a PG blog and you can you can
learn a little bit more about those the
final question can actually manage API
service applications we are consuming
absolutely yes the answer is very
similar to the first one as long as it
is an API as long as there is an HTTP or
HTTPS based protocol absolutely Apogee
can address those so with that that's
the last question which we have is there
any follow-ups we are going to address
those online and state you'll for the
next session auto ml vision making
custom image analytic analysis possible
for every business thank you and have a
great day
you
you